Sergey Brin: Quiero comentar un problema
que sé que os ha agobiado a muchos.
Hablamos aquí por última vez hace varios años.
Y antes de empezar hoy,
ya que muchos os lo preguntáis,
quería dejarlo claro desde el principio.
La respuesta es, calzoncillos.
Espero que ahora todos os sintáis mejor.
¿Alguien sabe qué puede ser esto? ¿Alguien sabe lo que es?
Público: Sí.
SB: ¿Qué es?
Público: Es la gente que se conecta a Google en todo el mundo.
SB: ¡Guau! Bien. La verdad, yo no supe lo que era la primera vez que lo vi.
Pero esto fue lo que me ayudó a entenderlo.
Esto es lo que tenemos puesto en la oficina, en realidad es en tiempo real.
Aquí va un poco retrasado.
Pero se puede ver cómo usa Google
la gente repartida por el mundo.
Cada uno de esos puntos que se levantan
representa probablemente unas 20 ó 30 búsquedas,
o algo por el estilo.
Están clasificados por colores, por idiomas.
Se ve claramente: aquí estamos en los EE.UU.,
y todos se muestran en rojo.
Esto es Monterrey -- espero no equivocarme.
Se puede ver que en Japón hay movimiento de noche,
justo ahí.
Aquí está Tokio con búsquedas en japonés.
Hay mucha actividad en China.
Hay mucha actividad en India.
Un poco en Oriente Medio, pequeños cúmulos.
Y Europa, donde ahora es exactamente mediodía,
tiene un gran tráfico, con una gran cantidad de idiomas.
También se puede ver, si giro esto por aquí --
espero no agitar el planeta demasiado.
Pero también se puede ver que hay lugares sin mucho tráfico.
Australia, simplemente porque hay poca población.
Y esto es algo en lo que de verdad deberíamos trabajar,
se trata de África, con sólo unos pequeños puntos,
básicamente en Sudáfrica y unos cuantos centros urbanos.
Pero básicamente, lo que hemos notado es que estas búsquedas,
que llegan en miles por segundo,
están disponibles donde hay electricidad.
Casi siempre ocurre que, donde hay electricidad hay Internet.
Incluso en la Antártida -- bueno, al menos esta época del año --
a veces se da un aumento de una búsqueda concreta.
Si se trazara correctamente, creo que en la Estación Espacial Internacional
creo que la Estación Espacial Internacional la tendría también.
Así que
parte del reto que se nos plantea,
es, como podéis ver, que es difícil obtener el --
aquí está.
Así es como debemos mover los bits
para llevar a la gente las respuestas a sus preguntas.
Se ve que hay mucha información en movimiento.
Debe atravesar todo el mundo: a través de fibra óptica,
a través de satélites, a través de todo tipo de conexiones.
Resulta muy complicado mantener las latencias
todo lo bajas que podemos. Esperamos que vuestra experiencia sea buena.
Pero, de nuevo, se puede ver -- algunos lugares están más conectados
que otros, y se puede ver todo el ancho de banda en EE.UU.,
que va hasta Asia, Europa en la otra dirección, y así sucesivamente.
Ahora me gustaría mostraros
cómo es un segundo de actividad del sistema.
Y si podemos cambiar a diapositivas --
bien, allá vamos.
Bien, esto está ralentizado.
Así es un segundo del sistema.
Así pasamos gran parte de nuestro tiempo,
tan sólo asegurándonos de que podemos asumir
semejante tráfico de datos.
Bien, cada una de esas búsquedas
tiene una interesante vida y trayectoria propia.
Es decir, podría tratarse de la salud de alguien,
podría ser la carrera profesional de alguien, algo importante.
Y podría existir la posibilidad de que sea algo
tan importante como la salsa de tomate,
o en este caso,el ketchup.
Pues bien, esta es una búsqueda que tuvimos --
Creo que es un grupo famoso, que fue más conocido en unas partes del mundo que en otras.
Se puede ver que empezó justo aquí.
En EE.UU. y España, tuvo popularidad al mismo tiempo.
Pero no tuvo la misma acogida en EE.UU.
que en España.
Y luego, de España pasó a Italia,
después Alemania se entusiasmó, y quizá ahora el Reino Unido lo está disfrutando.
Así que supongo que al final en EE.UU.
empezó a gustar también.
Quería ponerla para que la escuchemos.
Sea como sea, la podéis disfrutar vosotros mismos --
seguramente esa búsqueda servirá.
Como parte de --
ya sabéis, parte de lo que queremos hacer para expandir la empresa
es tener más búsquedas.
Lo que eso significa es que queremos tener
más personas sanas y formadas.
Más animales, si ellos también empiezan a hacer búsquedas.
Pero en parte, queremos hacer del mundo un lugar mejor,
para ello, algo que estamos desarrollando es la Fundación Google,
ahora estamos poniéndolo en marcha.
También tenemos un programa llamado Google Grants,
que actualmente ayuda a más de 150 organizaciones benéficas de todo el mundo,
éstas son algunas de las organizaciones bajo su auspicio.
Es algo de lo que me emociona formar parte.
De hecho, muchas de las organizaciones presentes aquí --
el Acumen Fund, creo que ApproTEC también, no estoy seguro del todo --
y muchas de las personas que han venido aquí se benefician de Google Grants.
Los participantes incluyen anuncios de Google, y nosotros les damos los ingresos que generan,
para dar a conocer sus organizaciones.
Uno de los primeros resultados que tuvimos --
tenemos a un empresario de Singapur que ahora patrocina una aldea
de 25 mujeres jóvenes vietnamitas para costearles la educación,
ese fue uno de los primeros resultados. Como decía, ahora ha habido
muchos, muchos casos parecidos,
porque hay cientos de organizaciones benéficas inscritas,
y la Fundación Google será una iniciativa aún más amplia.
Bueno, ¿sabe alguien qué es esto?
¡Ajá!
Público: Orkut.
SB: ¡Si! Alguien lo ha reconocido.
Éste es Orkut. ¿Alguien de aquí usa Orkut?
¿Alguien?
Bueno, no hay muchas personas que lo conozcan.
Lo explicaré en un instante.
Este es uno de nuestros ingenieros.
Hemos averiguado que trabajan mejor si están sumergidos y cubiertos de hojas.
Así es como sacamos nuestros productos.
Orkut tuvo la visión de crear una red social.
Sé que todos estáis pensando, "Otra red social".
Pero esto era su sueño, y nosotros, básicamente,
cuando alguien de verdad quiere hacer algo, bueno, normalmente se lo permitimos.
Así que creó esto.
Lo lanzamos en fase de pruebas el mes pasado,
y ha empezado a despegar.
Éste es nuestro Vicepresidente de Ingeniería.
Se ve el pelo rojo, y no se si pueden ver aquí su piercing en la naríz.
Todos estos son sus amigos.
Así es como -- lo acabamos de poner en marcha --
decidimos que la gente se enviaría invitaciones para acceder al servicio,
por tanto, al principio sólo los miembros de la empresa las enviaban.
Ahora hemos llegado a tener más de 100.000 miembros.
Se han propagado muy rápido, incluso fuera de Estados Unidos.
Se puede ver, si bien EE.UU. sigue suponiendo la mayoría --
por cierto, en número de búsquedas sólo supone el 30 por ciento de nuestro tráfico.
Pero ya empieza a extenderse por Japón, Reino Unido y Europa,
y el resto de países.
Es un proyecto pequeño y entretenido.
Hay gran variedad de datos demográficos. No os aburriré con ellos.
Es justo el tipo de cosas que probamos por diversión
y para ver hasta dónde llegan.
Y --
bueno, voy a mantener el suspense.
Larry, puedes explicar esto.
Larry Page: Gracias, Sergey.
Pues una de las cosas -- Sergey y yo
fuimos a un colegio en Montessori,
y creo que, por alguna razón,
esto ha pasado a ser parte de Google.
Sergey mencionó Orkut, que es algo que,
como sabéis, Orkut quería hacer en su horario de trabajo,
así que lo llamamos -- en Google, llamamos a esto "el 20 por ciento del tiempo."
La idea es que, el 20 por ciento de tu horario,
si trabajas en Google, puedes hacer lo que creas que es mejor.
Y muchísimas cosas han surgido así en Google,
como Orkut y también Google Noticias.
Y creo que muchas otras cosas en el mundo han surgido de igual modo.
Mendel, que supuestamente daba clase a estudiantes de secundaria,
en realidad, como sabéis, descubrió las leyes de la genética --
básicamente como pasatiempo.
Y muchísimas cosas útiles han surgido así.
Noticias, lo que acabo de mencionar,
fue iniciado por un investigador.
Y él -- después del 11-S, se interesó mucho por las noticias.
Y pensó, "¿Por qué no puedo ver las noticias de forma más cómoda?"
Así que empezó a agruparlas por categoría,
empezó a usar el sistema, y después sus amigos empezaron a usarlo.
Y entonces, además de hacer que quede bien en la foto de un bebé
lo convertimos en un "Googlette",
que básicamente es un mini-proyecto en Google.
El caso era tener unas tres personas más o menos,
que intenten crear un producto.
No sabíamos si iba a funcionar o no.
En el caso de Google News, hubo dos personas
que dedicaron un tiempo a crearlo; después cada vez más gente
empezó a usarlo, y acabamos poniéndolo en Internet,
con lo que cada vez más gente empezó a usarlo.
Ahora es un proyecto de entidad, con más personas dedicadas a él.
Así es como mantenemos activa la innovación.
Creo que suele ocurrir, a medida que las empresas crecen,
que les cuesta tener proyectos pequeños e innovadores.
Nosotros también tuvimos este problema, hasta que dijimos
"Definitivamente necesitamos un nuevo concepto".
Ahí están los Googlettes -- un proyecto pequeño que no sabemos si funcionará.
Pero esperamos que funcione, y si generamos suficientes,
algunos de ellos funcionarán de verdad, como Google News.
Pero nos encontramos con un problema, porque teníamos más de 100 proyectos.
No sé vosotros,
pero a mí me cuesta mantener 100 cosas en la cabeza a la vez.
Descubrimos que si las escribíamos
y ordenábamos -- éstas de aquí son inventadas.
No les prestéis atención.
Por ejemplo, "Comprar Islandia" lo sacamos de un artículo.
Nunca haríamos algo tan absurdo. Pero --
sea como sea, vimos que apuntándolos y ordenándolos,
casi todo el mundo estaba de acuerdo sobre el orden correcto.
Esto supuso una sorpresa para mí, pero
pudimos ver que mientras se tengan esas 100 cosas en la cabeza,
lo que se consigue escribiéndolas,
se pueden tomar buenas decisiones sobre qué hacer
y a qué dedicar los recursos.
Así que eso es lo que hemos hecho
desde que lo pusimos en práctica hace unos años, y creo que nos ha permitido innovar
y a la vez seguir estando bien organizados.
Lo otro que averiguamos es que a la gente le gusta trabajar en cosas importantes,
y de modo natural,
la gente fluye hacia aquello que es una gran prioridad.
Quería destacar un par de cosas
que son nuevas, o que quizá no conozcáis.
La de arriba es el Deskbar.
Es un nuevo -- ¿cuántos usan la Barra de Herramientas de Google?
Levantad la mano.
¿Cuántos usan el Deskbar?
Bueno, os recomiendo que lo probéis.
Pero si vais a nuestra web y buscáis
"Deskbar," os saldrá esto.
La idea es que, en vez de una barra de herramientas, está presente constantemente
en la parte inferior de la pantalla,
y se pueden hacer búsquedas muy fácilmente.
Es como una versión mejorada de la barra de herramientas.
Gracias, Sergey.
Éste es otro ejemplo de un proyecto que a alguien de Google
le apasionaba, y lo -- siguieron con ello,
es un producto verdaderamente bueno, está despegando.
Google Answers es algo que pusimos en marcha, es muy chulo,
te permite -- pagando entre cinco y 100 dólares
escribir una pregunta,
y hay un conjunto de investigadores
que investigan por ti, está garantizado etc,
y se pueden obtener respuestas muy buenas
sin invertir todo ese tiempo por uno mismo.
Froogle te permite buscar información sobre compras,
y Blogger sirve para publicar cosas.
Pero todos estos -- todos eran ideas innovadoras que pusimos en marcha que --
como sabéis, probamos muchas cosas diferentes
en nuestra empresa.
También nos gusta innovar en nuestro espacio físico,
y nos dimos cuenta de que en las reuniones hay que esperar mucho tiempo
a que los proyectores se enciendan y apaguen,
y como son ruidosos, la gente los apaga.
No nos gustó, así que
en unas dos semanas construimos estas pequeñas cajas
que albergan los proyectores, así que podemos dejarlos siempre encendidos
y no se escucha ningún ruido.
Gracias a esto creamos nuevo software
que nos sirve para gestionar una reunión,
de modo que ahora, cuando entras en una sala de juntas,
se muestra un listado de todas las reuniones programadas,
se pueden tomar notas muy fácilmente y se envían por e-mail automáticamente
a todas las personas que asistieron a la reunión.
A medida que nos convertimos en una empresa global,
vemos que este tipo de cosas nos afecta --
por ejemplo, ¿podemos trabajar más eficientemente con personas que no están en la sala?
Ese tipo de cosas. Las cosas sencillas como esta pueden suponer una gran diferencia.
También tenemos a muchos ingenieros en estas reuniones,
que no lavan la ropa con tanta frecuencia como es de esperar.
Nos dimos cuenta de que resultaba de mucha ayuda
disponer de lavanderías, especialmente para los empleados más jóvenes, y ...
también permitimos que traigan a sus perros y demás,
tenemos, creo yo, un ambiente muy divertido en nuestra empresa,
lo que ayuda a que la gente trabaje y disfrute con lo que hace.
Esta es nuestra foto estilo "secta."
Quería enseñarla brevemente.
La tuvimos puesta en la web un tiempo,
pero nos dimos cuenta
de que ya no recibíamos solicitudes de empleo.
De cualquier modo, cada año llevamos
a toda la empresa a esquiar.
Gran parte del trabajo en las empresas se realiza gracias a la gente se conoce.
Creo que hemos conseguido animar a que sea así.
Hace que sea un lugar estupendo para trabajar.
Junto a nuestros logotipos, que creo que realmente personifican
nuestra cultura de cambiar las cosas.
Durante los comienzos, nos aconsejaron
que nunca cambiáramos nuestro logotipo porque
debíamos dar a conocer la marca,
porque, como ya sabéis, uno nunca querría cambiar su logotipo.
Quieres que sea consistente.
Pensamos "Vaya, no parece muy divertido.
¿Y si lo cambiamos cada día?"
Una de las cosas que me apasiona de lo que estamos haciendo ahora
es lo que llamamos AdSense,
esto es en parte predicción --
es de antes de que Dean se fuera.
Pero el concepto es, por ejemplo como en un periódico,
mostrar anuncios relevantes.
Cuesta leerlo, pero dice "La batalla de New Hampshire:
Howard Dean presidente" -- artículos sobre Howard Dean.
Estos anuncios se generan automáticamente --
como en este caso, en el Washington Post --
a partir del contenido del sitio.
Así que usamos nuestros más de 150.000 anunciantes
y millones de anuncios, para escoger
el más relevante de acuerdo a lo que estás leyendo,
como hacemos con las búsquedas.
La idea es que podemos hacer que la publicidad sea útil,
no sólo molesta, ¿verdad?
Lo bueno de esto
es que hay un programa que los distribuye automáticamente,
muchos miles de sitios web se han registrado,
pudiendo así ganar dinero.
Conozco a muchas personas --
conocí a un tipo que gestiona una web de conservación en un partido,
que me contó: "¿Sabes? No ganaba nada de dinero.
Acabo de poner esto en mi sitio web y estoy ganando 10.000 dólares al mes.
Así que, gracias.
Ya no tengo que dedicarme a mi otro trabajo."
Creo que es algo muy importante para nosotros, porque hace que Internet funcione mejor.
Hace que los contenidos sean mejores, que la búsqueda funcione mejor,
cuando la gente puede ganarse la vida
produciendo buenos contenidos.
Como esta conferencia supuestamente trata sobre el futuro,
voy a hablar un poco sobre él.
El concepto tras esto es que, para conseguir que las búsquedas sean perfectas,
hay que ser muy inteligente.
Porque puedes escribir cualquier búsqueda en Google,
y esperas obtener una respuesta, ¿cierto?
Pero encontrar cosas es complicado, así que en realidad hace falta inteligencia.
De hecho, el motor de búsqueda definitivo debería ser inteligente.
Sería inteligencia artificial.
Así que es algo en lo que estamos trabajando,
incluso tenemos personas suficientemente entusiasmadas
y suficientemente locas para trabajar ahora en ello,
es realmente su objetivo.
Así que deseamos que Google sea inteligente,
pero siempre nos sorprendemos cuando otras personas creen que lo es.
Quería mostrar un simpático ejemplo de esto.
Esto es un blog sobre Irak,
no es realmente
de lo que voy a hablar, pero quería mostrar un ejemplo.
Sergey, a lo mejor puedes resaltar esto.
Pues decidimos --
en realidad sí quería resaltar eso. Gracias.
Bien, "búsquedas relacionadas," justo ahí. No se ve muy bien,
pero decidimos añadir una función
a nuestros anuncios AdSense, llamada "búsquedas relacionadas."
Así que pone, ya sabéis, "Quizás quiso decir" -- a ver,
en este caso pone "Saddam Hussein," porque es un blog sobre Irak --
además de los anuncios,
creímos que sería una gran idea.
Pues bien, tenemos este blog
de un joven que estaba algo deprimido, y comentaba,
"Estoy durmiendo muchísimo".
Escribía cosas sobre su vida.
Y nuestros algoritmos -- no una persona, por supuesto,
sino nuestro algoritmos, nuestros ordenadores --
leyeron su blog y concluyeron que
la búsqueda relacionada era "estoy aburrido".
Entonces él lo leyó, y creyó que otra persona había decidido
que él era aburrido,
y muy desgraciado,
así que dijo, "Oye, ¿qué están haciendo los, o sea, los cabrones de Google?"
¿Por qué no les gusta mi blog?"
Así que cuando leímos su blog, que iba -- en fin,
iba de mal en peor,
nuestro sistema decidió que la búsqueda relacionada era "Retrasados mentales."
Con lo que se enfadó aún más,
y escribió -- empezó a poner insultos y demás.
Y nuestro sistema indicó "Eres penoso."
Y al final, acabó con "Bésame el culo".
Esencialmente, pensó que estaba tratando con algo inteligente,
y por supuesto, como sabéis,
simplemente escribimos un programa y lo pusimos a prueba,
no funcionó del todo,
y ya no ofrecemos esta función.
Dicho esto, querría volver al ámbito mundial.
Quería acabar diciendo que
hay un par de cosas que realmente me entusiasman
de participar en Google,
y una de ellas es que podemos ganar dinero
principalmente con la publicidad, y uno de los beneficios que no anticipé que esto tendría
fue que podemos dar servicio a cualquier persona del mundo
sin preocuparnos, y sabéis, de lugares que no tienen tanto dinero.
Así que no tenemos que preocuparnos de que, por ejemplo,
nuestros productos se vendan por menos dinero en países pobres,
y después vuelvan a importarse de vuelta a EE.UU. --
como ocurre, por ejemplo, con las farmacéuticas.
Creo que somos afortunados de tener ese tipo de modelo de negocio,
porque todo el planeta tiene acceso a nuestras búsquedas,
y opino que es un beneficio muy, muy grande.
Lo otro que quería mencionar brevemente
es que tenemos un grandísimo poder y responsabilidad
de proporcionar la información adecuada a la gente,
y nos vemos a nosotros mismos como un periódico o revista --
en el sentido de que debemos dar información objetiva.
Por esto, nunca aceptamos dinero para nuestros resultados de búsqueda orgánica.
Aceptamos dinero por la publicidad,
y la anunciamos como tal.
Esto no ocurre con muchos de nuestros competidores.
Pienso que las decisiones de ese tipo que tomamos
tienen un enorme impacto en el mundo,
y hace que esté muy orgulloso de formar parte de Google.
Así que gracias.